hey there and welcome to the motion
science video blog my name is Cameron
and today we're going to talk about
remote artists tips specifically I've
got three of them for you so stay tuned
and find out what those are
[Music]
hey there and welcome back to the video
blog as I said my name is Cameron I'm
glad to have you here today with me to
watch this very important video for
those of you who are remote artists
specifically freelancers if you're not a
remote artist you're still gonna get
some good information out of this if you
work from home which during the time of
this recording we are under a lockdown
pretty much globally for a pandemics
pandemic so these are really important
tips for you working as a remote artists
now or in the future so what are my tips
for you so the first tip is actually the
very most the most important tip of all
of them okay it's a little bit longer
tip but tip number one is to set strong
boundaries okay so what does set strong
boundaries me it means many different
things okay now I've been a remote
artist for since 2007 I've had a little
bit of time where I've gone to studios
and worked at studios but for the most
part since 2007 I've been a remote
artist and I've had to learn what works
and what doesn't work in terms of
setting strong boundaries the first and
most important item when it comes to
setting strong boundaries is yourself
okay you need a daily routine you need
to wake up every day at the same time
you need to set an alarm you get up at
the same time you need to have that same
morning routine I'm a big believer in
getting up and not checking your email
and not getting on social media not
getting on your phone right away but
doing some type of routine for yourself
you know what that is is totally up to
you there's things like meditation
there's things like goal-setting there's
a lot of different things you can do for
yourself that just take like 10 minutes
but you get up and you get up the same
time every day you do some routine for
yourself you do whatever it is you need
to do and then you start your like maybe
you go to the gym
I'm certain one of the gym right now
maybe work on a home that's what I'm
doing
and then you get to work like you eat
breakfast and you get to work right and
you you work there's different
strategies you can take for working some
people believe that you work twenty five
minutes in and you're you're hardcore
into some tasks and then you stop for
five minutes and you actually set an
alarm right that's a whole different
topic of how you can actually accomplish
things that you want to accomplish but
you just need to have some type of a
routine for your work schedule so maybe
you work from maybe you get up let's say
at 8:00 a.m. okay and you do your
morning routine you start working at
10:00 a.m. and you maybe you work till
1:00 p.m. right so you work for three
hours and then you you give yourself
that time to break you have lunch you
want to walk I'm a big believer and you
get out inside nature living where I
live I can get out in nature I can walk
around it's great to clear your head and
just take some time to just breathe and
separate yourself from technology right
and then maybe you come back maybe you
do a an hour break and then you come
back and you say hey I'm gonna work
three or four more hours and I'm gonna
break for for dinner and maybe you have
to put a little bit time in at night or
maybe you're done for the day it's it's
up to you but you need to honor your
time daily for you to accomplish
whatever it is you're trying to
accomplish if you're an animator if you
need to animate a project if you're a
designer if you need to design that
project if you're self-employed and
you're trying to run a business whatever
it is as a remote artist you need to
honor yourself you need to honor your
time and you need to set a daily routine
okay this is how you're gonna get things
done it's it's very easy as a remote
artist to say well I'll just I'll get up
when I wake up and I'll do what I needed
to do and then I'll get to work and I'll
get things done and before you know it
life gets in the way right like if you
have a significant other if you have
kids especially I've done this for like
I said since 2007 and I've had several
kids along the way that they like to
jump in the way and get your attention
so it's very important that if they know
that routine and you know that routine
that you can get things accomplished and
that brings me to another point about
setting strong boundaries which is your
spouse or your roommate or significant
other your kids they need to know what
your routine is as well so that they can
honor that and give you the time that
you need because if you're maybe you're
the main provider if you can't provide
for them then you know what is there to
their life right they they rely on you
to provide for them so they need to
allow you to do what you need to do to
provide for them okay and it's also
important to remember that when you are
working through your task for the day
I'm something I keep in mind as I always
have three major tasks I want to
accomplish for the day and not more than
three sometimes I'm tempted to do more
than three but in reality if you set
three big goals for yourself during that
day you're gonna most likely accomplish
those goals and maybe a few small things
in between those goals
but whatever that is don't set more than
three three goals for yourself and and
give your it allow yourself to just to
take the time to accomplish what you're
trying to accomplish right just put one
step in front of the other and just take
baby steps all you have to do is take a
step and then another step another step
and before you know it you'll you'll
accomplish whatever it is you're trying
to to get done so like let's say your
remote artist and you're designing for a
client and you've got a design project
or you're animating for a client and
you're you're nervous about that aspect
of the job because you don't quite know
how to do it and some of us will get
paralyzed by that fear and put it off
put it off put it off until the last
minute and then we know you know the
deadlines coming up and we haven't done
it yet and we freaked out we stress out
we stay up all night and maybe we
deliver a mediocre in product whereas if
we would just start and tackle those
those goals those those hurdles at the
beginning then you're like I said if you
take another step and then another step
you're gonna mostly you're going to be
more apt to
accomplish that goal right um also if
you find yourself constantly distracted
and not wanting to work something need
to keep in mind is that you may be
misaligned or not true to yourself about
what it is that you enjoy doing okay
we've all been there and we have been
flow through our lives right so there's
been times when I thought as a remote
artist that I wanted to do this project
a and I found that I got project a and I
didn't really enjoy it I was distracted
and I just wanted to do other things
instead of that project and then I got
project B and I found that was really
cold to that project and it really like
creatively fulfilled me and I found that
I could it was easy for me to sustain
that motivation to keep focused on that
goal because it was it was more aligned
with what I would really wanted to do so
there's nothing wrong with this changing
our goals and our focus if we're not
aligned with what it is that we're
working on now that doesn't mean that if
you're in the mill of a project that you
just stopped the project and say hey I'm
not aligned with this project I'm gonna
move on now you know you're gonna lose
that client and you don't want to treat
your clients like that so just be aware
of that it's it's so critical it's so
important that you stay true to you
right and that you honor you and you
honor your time so that you can stay
aligned with the type of projects that
will keep you going day after day after
day and not getting out of those
boundaries and getting distracted
something else
one more point I want to add about
setting strong boundaries is that it's
also very important that you have a
separate location within your home for
your office okay now when I started out
as a remote freelancer I'll be honest my
separate location was actually a small
desk in my dining room right I had a
really small house it was just me and my
two kids and they were young and we had
is a tiny house so we had our kitchen a
little tiny kitchen in a little tiny
dining room and a little tiny living
room and then we had our two bedrooms
and for the longest time that I put a
little a table in my dining room away
from
corner away from the dining room table
and that was my office and that was
where I when I sat down at that desk
that's what i sat there to do i sat
there to work and to get my jobs done
and my kids knew that because I put the
expectations I set the boundaries with
them and said when dad's sitting here
working that means I can't be distracted
unless it's very very important right
and then later on I moved that desk into
my bedroom into a corner because I
actually had a larger bedroom and that
desk became my workstation in my bedroom
now
it's never a good idea and unless you're
forced into a situation like that you
don't want to put your working desk in
your bedroom you want to keep those
separate okay because what you'll find
is all of a sudden your work life and
your personal life are going to become
so intertwined that it's hard to
distinguish the difference and it can be
very detrimental to personal
relationships if you have no work life
personal life separation so ideally like
today in my situation today is I have a
separate bedroom in my home that is can
devoted to my office and this is where I
record and this is where I work and
that's what this room is for it's not a
playroom for the kids it's not a you
know sometimes it becomes a guest room
when we have guests here but this is my
office and this is where I walk into
this door I walk into this room to
record and that's what I do
so set strong boundaries that is my
number one tip for you and that's my
biggest tip for you is to set strong
boundaries with yourself and with the
other members of your family and friends
around you so that you can stay
motivated and you could continue to do
to accomplish what it is you need to
accomplish okay so tip number two tip
two and three a little bit shorter tip
number one is very very important
remember that okay tip number two is to
optimize your work time okay and that
can be a number of things one it can
give you some some little nuggets about
optimizing work time
the the one thing that's the biggest for
me is Dropbox okay I use Dropbox because
I use two computers three computers
sometimes and Dropbox I pay for a high
tiered account with them so that I have
something like I don't know two
terabytes of storage or something like
that and what it what it allows me an I
have used Dropbox for years right for
years and years years and what it
allowed means allows me to do is I could
work on machine number one do what I
need to do everything is saved on
Dropbox write all my file structures are
on Dropbox which is an SSD drive on my
computer so it's important to have an
SSD drive because they're quick but that
draw so I work on my my Dropbox folder
locations I work with my files like any
other file but instead of being on my
local computer which they are they're
also synced on to Dropbox okay so and
then I can leave this computer I can go
to my laptop if I decide that I need
some outdoor time I want to work with my
laptop for a little bit I go up on my
laptop up and there is my folder it
syncs very quickly my folder structure
is there I can open up After Effects
Photoshop Illustrator cinema 4d on my
laptop and continue to work with my
files just like I did on my iMac in my
office right it's just it's
instantaneous and this is an enormous
file it has to sync up which can take a
little bit of time but for the most part
you have instantaneous access to all of
your files on every computer you work on
and it's awesome it has worked like I
said for me for years and it continues
to work for me um it also has a great
ability to backup files you can go back
and find versions of files if something
gets corrupted you can go into Dropbox
and find those files and bring them back
um it's also great there's been times in
my life where I've had also I've had a
home office I've had a separate office
in a separate location now I don't have
that right now but there's been times
I've had that and it's the same deal
I've got Dropbox on that computer so I
can work at home get in my car drive the
office open up the computer there
everything is synced ready to go
it's
okay it's also great for fallows sharing
with teams and with clients so I'm
working on my files I've rendered out my
files
everything's on Dropbox my render is
already there all I have to do is just
copy that link send it to my client they
can download it right off my Dropbox
right it's seamless it's so easy to work
with that it just saves me a ton of time
and I've said like I said I've done this
I've you drop much for years and I'm a
big big believer in it for optimizing my
work time I also use like I said two
three computers to keep me going because
what I find is is that if I'm working on
this machine and I've created a big
render and After Effects or cinema 4d
once I hit that render button if I'm in
the mode and I hit render and I know
it's gonna be down for thirty minutes an
hour several hours whatever overnight I
have a second laptop that I can turn to
right here we're going to separate room
and I can start working on that laptop
and continue doing what I need to do so
I would recommend that you always have
at least two computers and you probably
don't need more than two computers but
if you have two computers like a desktop
and a laptop you're always going to be
able to you know work on one system
while the other one is rendering and
vice versa I'm not a big believer in
multitasking to the point where if you
don't have to if you're not rendering
something that you're just looking at
preview here and you jump over here and
do something else I have fallen victim
to that in my own life and I find that
actually multitasking in the end
actually delays projects okay now
there's let me don't be honest with you
sometimes I still do it every once in a
while but I do get distracted and when
you get distracted things don't work as
well things don't the end product isn't
as good so just having a computer
essentially to render on and another
computer you can turn to and keep going
on when you're in that work mode is
ideal because we don't also want to be
in that mode hit render and then have to
stop being in that mode and come back
hours later to get
back into that mood right I think
there's a statistic out there I heard
once that said when you're in the middle
of like a motion design project every
time someone comes into you and says
something like hey can I get your
attention for a second
it actually takes you about 15 to 20
minutes to get back into that mode of
where you were at where you were at
creatively with your project it takes
you 15 to 20 minutes so if you think
about getting distracted multiple times
throughout the day or hitting render
buttons multiple times throughout the
day and having to stop it's you're
you're losing hours of valuable time
okay
my third remote artist tip for you today
is optimize your downtime so we just
talked about how you we optimize our
work time you also need to optimize your
downtime okay that that starts with
taking care of you so if you're in a
place where you've got lots of clients
and the works coming to you and you do
get some downtime take care of you and
take a break detach from the technology
get out nature refresh yourself and just
let your mind go and you'll find a lot
of times that you can get very creative
during these times without even thinking
like there's a lot to be try and force
creativity upon ourselves and we have to
because we always have to be creative
well if you can step away from that and
just relax and unplug you're gonna find
that it's really really good for you for
your soul for your your mind for your
body just the detach okay
if you're able to do that and you have a
lot of clients now if you're just
starting out as a remote artist since a
lot of you probably are right now if you
finish a job
don't go say hey I can go take a
vacation now right if you if you need
that next job you need to be focused on
where's that next job coming from okay
you need to focus on where's the next
I'll come home I need to send out my my
reel to different clients potential
clients get the word out there that I'm
looking for work you also need to learn
new skills okay that means that you can
learn new creative skills you can learn
new software skills you can learn new
you know features and plugins
push yourself just just be creative on
your own time and you're gonna find it
you're going to become a better artist
right now I'm not saying that
Elson you got downtime and let's say
you're an After Effects cinema4d artists
don't take that downtime and say oh I
better go learn her Houdini right
Ramaiah or or X particles don't don't
focus on that and I have another video
about that of having software and
hardware overwhelm this doesn't mean you
go learn those you focus in on what
you're really good at so for me it's
After Effects
so if I have downtime I'm gonna go in
and I'm gonna say hey there's a plug-in
up in one to explore there's a technique
I've been wanting to explore a process a
workflow I'm gonna go in and I'm going
to start exploring that and use my
downtime appropriately to become better
as an artist right others are think
about making dailies maybe it's you're
making creative work every day in your
downtime to get better right so that's a
great way to optimize your downtime it's
also really good to just create spec
work which falls into these categories
of learning new skills and pushing
yourself create new spec work and use
that spec work to build your reel or to
optimize your reel there's nothing wrong
with having a reel and replacing one or
two pieces or three pieces I do it all
the time right
I if I find that I've created something
amazing there's no reason you have to
wait a year or two years to show that
work off put it in your reel right I'm
not a big believer in dating your reels
anyways because then it is a constant
you know hassle of like hope here's my
2020 reel now here's my 20 21 real
here's one 20 20 22 real why not just
have a real focus on what you do really
well and just update it right maybe you
wanted you know every once why you want
to change the musical' that's great that
is like creating a new reel but there's
nothing wrong with replacing pieces and
if you don't have the client work create
the spec pieces create the work that
creatively fulfills you it's the work
that you're that you that you love to do
and it's the work that's going on your
reel which then goes out to put your
potential clients
then attracts those potential clients
because they're looking for that same
type of work that what as what you do
and it's just it's just a really good
way to optimize your downtime so like I
said if you're fortunate enough that
you've got lots of clients and you've
got a little bit of break detach take
the time off if you don't have those
clients and knew that work you need that
income right away you know get out there
in front of the clients show them your
real make your real better and continue
to learn and push yourself creatively
and get better at what you do
so those are my three tips for remote
artists today I know that you know these
are these are very powerful tips these
are tips that have worked for me since
2007 I know what I'm doing as a remote
artists I've had a lot of ups and downs
but what I do now works so keep pushing
yourself get out there do what you got
to do make amazing work
I would always invite you to check out
more of what motion science TV has to
offer we do have a freelancing course if
you want to learn even more about how to
go remote freelance definitely check out
the freelance effect until next time
thanks for checking out this blog I'm
Cameron and this is motion science see
ya
[Music]
you